here's a tricky no calculator question  what is the approximate area of the  region defined by the equations x minus  6 squared plus y minus 4 squared is less  than or equal to 100 and X and Y are  greater than or equal to zero we have a  circle with Center 6 4 and we're given  the point 0 12 6 14 and 16 4. the values  are between 75 and 125 125 and 175 175  and 225 225 and 275 and 275 and 325. to  work this out we'll break the areas into  areas that we can calculate easily we  have a quarter circle with the radius  equal to 10 so that'll be pi over 4  multiplied by 10 squared here we have a  rectangle with dimensions of 14 and 6 so  its area is 14 times 6 and here we have  a rectangle with dimensions of 10 and 4  so its area is 10 times 4. now Pi is  approximately equal to 3 so we have 75  plus 84 plus 40 which is 199 and that  gives us the correct answer choice  between 175 and 225.